how's it going bros my name is peter and
welcome to five web stuff online have
you ever wanted Jesus inside you now we
can grow inside you
hmmm I wonder what Jesus tastes like
let's try it whatever you do do not
drink Jesus can't be that bad we'll
check back with Jesus later so if you
haven't figured it out already this
episode of five word stuff online is
themed around science the next item is
liquid glass
yeah safety first
the [ __ ] is this can I touch it
this is like the hair gel I put in my
hair oh my god what the [ __ ] what does
[ __ ] is this ah ah ah this is the same
product I use for my hair
can't [ __ ] read me these scold it
bounce it
can you drink it it feels like gel that
doesn't gel it's very strong oh boy the
last one was good wasn't it worth a
thumbs up now the next item is sculpt
your own boy so it comes with a room
that's not it's it has a girlfriend
there and I assume that's us let's begin
this is our reference point oh wow a fan
gave me this one
Amanda Stacy and Jennings oh no you know
who a boyfriend I want to make a nakida
all right so these are the legs done
this is the torso now we're going to use
this fork to sculpt the biceps my
boyfriend will have a six-pack all right
pretty good why is the [ __ ] legs so
big compared to the torso
next up his face alright let's put his
eyes and there we go we used two liquid
glass to make angel wings
this is shining Hitler he's doing
push-ups there we go he lives happily he
waits for his me and god damn it stop so
yes you can see it's pretty accurate I
would say pretty good pretty good
item number four is a item number four
is some sweets huh pretty good thank you
I got for this to have a piggy this item
is probably one of the weirdest ones
we've ever had on the channel the
weirdest thing you could buy online
snails
this is Donald he's a little shy but I
thought it was dead for the longest time
but he's fine
Arnold he's quite the climber this is
Stallone okay okay
John Cena oh god John Cena let go there
you go John Cena oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
jean-claude is in there but he's a
little shine these all are gonna go on a
tournament next month in the great snail
race so leave your fav favorite comment
who you think is going to win the
comment I'm gonna go wash my head for
the final item we have indoor fireworks
I'm really excited to check these out um
it says use them indoors but we're gonna
do them out
all right it's your boy see boy pewter
pot we're going to do some of the
stickers indoor fireworks outdoor but
first safety don't forget that body all
right we got some ice fountains we're
gonna start with that insert fountain up
right on in soft ground all right this
should be pretty dope
Oh
ladies want to see a firework show yeah
all right all right
it's assess next up
just disco inferno oh [ __ ] it's all
falling out I don't know what I'm
supposed to do with these you want to
see some fireworks mate not everyone is
ready yeah you better back up a little
bit more man
no fair no fair
that's right DJ Carly it's been two days
Jesus Jesus has grown a lot this is how
much Jesus is grown and now you can live
with the snails
goodbye Jesus thank you for watching
fire stuff online if you enjoyed leave a
like and keep so we're showing your
support for the show it's a lot of fun
and as always stay awesome press don't
look at it this [ __ ] terrible